oh
this guy's crazy the dc fandom
literally made our domes explode let's
talk about the batman we finally got a
trailer for it so we're gonna break down
everything we know about the upcoming
batman reboot right now on the ketchup
it turns out that this tweet from
director matt reeves two days before dc
fandom revealing the official logo for
the batman
was just the tip of the bat cave because
despite the fact that they've only shot
about 20 percent of the film
much more was revealed at the dc fandom
virtual panel by rhys himself and by the
teaser trailer that he shared that i'm
sure by now you've watched a bajillion
times
you're becoming quite a celebrity for
starters the first look confirmed what
we've talked about on the ketchup in the
past but this will be
a gritty noir film focusing on a set of
serial murders along with corruption in
gotham city
and according to reeves the film will
take place in year two of batman's crime
fighting career so he'll be confronting
how he's perceived by the people of
gotham
who don't quite yet understand how he
exists and as many fans have pointed out
the batman's beatdown of a face painted
bad guy shows just how intense this
young crime fighter is going to be with
his style
and his attitude i mean i can't stop
thinking about this one line
i'm vengeance now you might be asking
even though i'm on your screen and i
can't hear you
what about the first year of batman's
crime fighting career well
funny you should ask because it was also
announced that the spin-off series for
hbo max that we've heard about will be
called gotham pd
it'll follow some of the city's corrupt
cops during batman's first year
there's no word yet on a release date
for that but maybe sometime around
october of 2021 to go with the movie
maybe and while we know that this is not
an origin story for batman
reeves did say it is in a sense for some
of the villains who we got to see in
action for the first time
like zoe kravitz's catwoman who's
clearly some sort of cat burglar and is
not afraid to throw down with the batman
we were also introduced to the highly
anticipated paul danos duct tape
wielding riddler character
who seems to have a major issue with the
batman and looks to be a very central
piece of this film plus we saw colin
farrell in some
serious makeup and transformation as the
penguin along with jeffrey ray as
commissioner gordon
who already seems to be on good working
terms with the batman i'm assuming
they've done a bunch of zoom meetings
together
any of this mean anything to you as far
as robert pattinson's batman well we
pretty much got the trifecta a better
look at the bat suit
seeing the batmobile in action and what
is most likely a first look at the
batcave which by the way looks like the
foyer of a rundown old mansion
and is pretty dope speaking of the suit
reeves confirmed that it's homemade and
bruce is still making adjustments love
it
and the batmobile well it's clearly had
some adjustments made to it as well and
i couldn't be more stoked
check out our ketchup episode on more
details of the batmobile if you haven't
already
also let's take a moment to appreciate
that a batman film is finally
acknowledging that batman clearly wears
black makeup around his eyes when he's
in the suit
i mean that was my favorite part about
george clooney's batman
alright bat fans it is time to back kick
it over to you now and i am done with
the bad puns but please let us know all
your thoughts and feelings in the
comments section and let us know if you
are excited for the batman
also keep an eye out for future episodes
on more dc updates like the snyder cut
the suicide squad
and wonder woman and so much more it's
gonna be so fun
also now is a great time to join our fan
group on facebook right now you can vote
on your favorite rotten movie for an
upcoming ketchup episode
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as
always muchas gracias for watching the
ketchup my name is az perez and my bad
suit is actually
not homemade bye
[Music]